welcome to this video playing endless
fighter from India again I played him
just a couple of minutes ago in this
session Salman this time we get an
English opening English Defence with b6
and let's see what happens here this is
an opening with Knight f6 that I'm yeah
I'm not saying I invented it probably
it's a yeah I'm probably just playing
something known but when I was faced
with this in a rapid game once I came up
with the night f6 idea he five Nagi form
I'm not really sure that it is good but
it's interesting leads to two sharp play
and he's got one problem in his position
this is the night on e to its really am
a bit misplaced hmm Knight g4 it's
completely wacky and also Queen a form
okay I probably need to just retreat
yeah the night only to it clocks up his
development this is a bit of a problem
on the other hand Jam it's not so clear
what my bishop is doing him okay
okay yeah I want to play 96 but d5 hangs
jam but on the other hand how do I
develop let's just let's just try to try
to make this work somehow if i take here
he's got a six year hmm now my original
intention was 94 but now that I look at
it I'm not sure 94 94 Bishop g5 was myit
was my idea okay so it's a blitz kami no
I wanted to tell but to wait wait wait
just for a moment what if i take it's
not necessarily bad Queen takes I have
Bishop c5 and castles maybe maybe and
I'm the d5 hang so it probably needs to
take that's that's interesting I thought
he needs to take
mm-hmm
he's got the check here of course
on a move like a day 95 you can check on
before but i have not know I don't have
96 hmm
b5 I can go be five no yes does not have
the check and Bishop e3 maybe 95 wow i
didn't i didn't see that one coming okay
i had bishop d5 before bed now I don't
we should be five
ah what does silly move I didn't see
that one huh
and nonsense ad didn't see it no
huh check ah what did position
yeah yeah I don't know maybe this is
strong but it's in a practical game this
is just terrible to play okay check yeah
yeah mate mid next move let's let's play
that's checkmate yeah daddy I forgot I
just I just overlook t6 it's a very
risky very risky play anyway but I need
to hey this is dead then this means this
is not working due to e6 simply I need
to play something like something like
that I mean this is not really great but
I probably must do that now you can I
can even cancel the bishop this is this
is quite ok actually get this annoyed
yeah ok that this means that probably
this is not ma'am I was cd4 maybe CD
phone I really don't think I'm in
terrible shape you I cannot really
believe that with the night only to the
port capture maybe yeah maybe that one
this is not so dangerous I can go here
it's even good for black now maybe I can
really just take here or here yeah of
course this is a very confusing position
with all the lights and the center
computer gives it as equal as after a
couple of seconds
they are very tricky very very tricky
okay probably my mistake is 96 i'ma just
for practical purposes I probably just
should just develop here like this and
Gasol with an unclear position i'm not
sure how to assess it both sides have
their pros and cons he's got this as bit
silly looking night but i have
potentially a week Bonilla it's probably
unclear turn yeah this was this was
straight away losing after he six I have
absolutely no defenses plus 3 yeah yeah
yeah and this is I mean I wasn't 100%
sure simply because I couldn't calculate
him the idis that lost plus 13 yeah
there are some some cute mates here like
this check yeah absolutely no defense at
all okay thanks for watching